RESISTANCE.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE" ."
TODAY THE WORLD WATCHED AS
DONALD TRUMP MADE GOOD ON HIS
PROMISE TO MOVE THE U.S. EMBASSY
IN ISRAEL TO JERUSALEM.
THREE PREVIOUS AMERICAN
PRESIDENTS HAD PROMISED TO DO
THIS.
>> JERUSALEM IS STILL THE
CAPITAL OF ISRAEL AND MUST
REMAIN AN UNDIVIDED CITY
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL.
>> AS SOON AS I TAKE OFFICE I
WILL BEGIN THE PROCESS OF MOVING
THE UNITED STATES AMBASSADOR TO
THE CITY OF    ISRAEL HAS CHOSEN
THE CITY OF    ISRAEL HAS CHOSEI
THE CITY OF    ISRAEL HAS CHOSES
CAPITAL.
>> JERUSALEM WILL REMAIN THE
CAPITAL OF ISRAEL AND IT MUST
REMAIN UNDIVIDED.
>> Laura: BUT ONE FROM
PROMISED, HE ACTUALLY DELIVERED.
REMEMBER, CONGRESS PASSED A LAW
AUTHORIZING THE EMBASSY TO MOVE
BACK IN 1995, BUT EVERY
PRESIDENT HAS DELAYED IT UNTIL
NOW.
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU, THE
PRIME MINISTER OF ISRAEL,
CELEBRATED THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THE MOMENT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP BECAME THE
FIRST WORLD LEADER TO RECOGNIZE
JERUSALEM AS OUR CAPITAL AND
TODAY THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA IS OPENING ITS EMBASSY
RIGHT HERE IN JERUSALEM.
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT TRUMP, FOR
HAVING THE COURAGE TO KEEP YOUR
PROMISES.
IT'S A GREAT DAY FOR OUR
FANTASTIC PARTNERSHIP, BUT I
BELIEVE IT'S ALSO A GREAT DAY
FOR PEACE.
>> Laura: OF COURSE IF ISRAEL
IS JUBILANT AND TRUMP CHALKS UP
ANOTHER ACHIEVEMENT, WELL WELL
WELL THE MEDIA REFLEXIVELY WHALE
AND FAILED POLITICIANS AND
DIPLOMATS OF YESTERYEAR GROUSE.
>> IT DOESN'T HELP.
TO SOME EXTENT IT HURTS, BUT IT
EXPOSES A LACK OF A DIPLOMATIC
STRATEGY.
I HOPE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS SEEING IT AND UNDERSTANDS
WHAT THE CONSEQUENCES ARE GOING
TO BE IF THEY DO ACTUALLY WANT
TO RESTART THE PEACE PROCESS.
>> THIS DECISION WAS ON BOARD
AND ON TETHERED.
PEACE PROCESS IS COMATOSE.
>> IN THE LONG RUN IT WILL NOT
ADVANCE PEACE PROCESS.
IT WILL MAKE HIS OWN POLICY MORE
DIFFICULT TO ACHIEVE AND
IMPLEMENT.
THAT'S THE REAL ISSUE, AND IT
GREATLY INFLAMES AN ALREADY VERY
>> Laura: AS OPPOSED TO WHAT?
GEORGE MITCHELL, WHAT YOU
NEGOTIATED?
LOOK, IF THE OLD GUARD, THE
SO-CALLED WISEMAN OF DIPLOMACY
KNEW SO MUCH, SUCH SMART GUYS,
WHY ARE WE STILL STRUGGLING IN
2018 TO BRING PEACE TO THE
REGION?
YOU HAD YOUR SHOT AND IT DIDN'T
WORK.
AND LET'S FACE IT.
NOW IT'S TRUMP'S TURN.
SO WHAT THE CRITICS FAILED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ENGAGED IN AN
INTERNATIONAL STRATEGY THAT IS
ALREADY PAYING SOME DIVIDENDS.
HE'S REMAKING ALLIANCES IN THE
MIDDLE EAST AND TAKING THE OLD
BARGAINING CHIPS OFF THE TABLE.
HE'S CHANGING THE OLD AND
FRANKLY THE STALE DYNAMIC THAT
WAS IN PLACE.
TRUMP IS A REORDERING THE
STATUS QUO AND HE'S FORCING OUR
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS INTO NEW
WAYS OF THINKING AND ACTING,
EVEN IF IT SEEMS UNCOMFORTABLE.
SAY WHAT YOU WANT, AND A LOT OF
YOU DO, ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S
APPROACH, BUT HE HAS
REINVIGORATED THE PROSPECTS OF
PEACE IN PLACES WE NEVER WOULD
HAVE THOUGHT CHANGE WHATEVER
HAPPENED.
AND HE'S CREATED NEW
POSSIBILITIES.
WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT ONLY A
YEAR AGO THAT NORTH KOREA WOULD
BE WILLING TO MELT DOWN ITS
NUCLEAR TESTING FACILITIES OR
EVEN COME TO THE NEGOTIATING
TABLE?
NO ONE THOUGHT THAT, EXCEPT
MAYBE PRESIDENT TRUMP HIMSELF.
AT HOME, THE ECONOMY IS BOOMING
AND THE PRESIDENT IS
DEMONSTRATING THAT BOLD,
INNOVATIVE LEADERSHIP CAN GET
REAL RESULTS ABROAD AND AT HOME.
HE'S APPOINTING TOPS ARE NOT
LEGAL MINDS TO THE FEDERAL
BENCH, WE KNOW THAT.
HE IS UNTANGLING REGULATIONS
THAT CHOKE, STIFLE AMERICAN
BUSINESSES LARGE AND SMALL.
AND NOW HE'S EVEN TACKLING
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICES.
HE DID THAT LAST WEEK AND IS
GOING TO BE WORKING ON THAT.
SO EVEN AS THE MEDIA ARE LOATH
TO COVER ANY OF THIS, AT LEAST
FAIRLY, THE PUBLIC I THINK GETS
IT.
SO TRUMP'S NUMBERS ARE CLIMBING.
BUT THE ONLY GROUP OF COURSE
THAT HASN'T GOTTEN THE MEMO IS
THE RESISTANCE MEDIA AND THEIR
PALS IN POLITICS.
THEY CONSISTENTLY IGNORE THE
PRESIDENT'S ACHIEVEMENTS WHILE
GRASPING AT ANY STRAW TO ASSAIL
HIM.
TODAY'S STRAW WAS A SIDE COMMENT
MADE LAST WEEK BY A WHITE HOUSE
AIDE DURING A PRIVATE MEETING
ABOUT AILING
SENATOR JOHN McCAIN.
>> A WHITE HOUSE AIDE MARKS HIM
AND THEY INTERJECT THAT THEY
STAND WITH THE PERSON MOCKING
JOHN McCAIN FOR HAVING BRAIN
CANCER.
>> THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN
APOLOGIES AND IT'S EASY TO
ASSUME THAT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WAS OKAY WITH THIS
BEING SAID.
>> SHE HAS STILL NOT PUBLICLY
APOLOGIZED AND SHE IS STILL AN
EMPLOYEE HERE AT THE
>> THIS SHOW SOMETHING ABOUT THE
CULTURE OF THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE
THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
POLITICS, LIBERAL, CONSERVATIVE,
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT.
THAT THERE HAS BEEN A KIND OF
INDECENCY THAT HAS BEEN
PERMITTED.
>> Laura: I'M SORRY.
I HAD TO BE AWAKEN FROM THAT
MONTAGE.
COME ON.
THE STAFF CALLED McCAIN'S
FAMILY PERSONALLY AND
APOLOGIZED.
THEY WANT A PUBLIC APOLOGY FOR
WHAT WAS A PRIVATE, LEAKED
COMMENT.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT THIS THIS
AFTERNOON.
CAN YOU IMAGINE WHAT TEAM OBAMA
SET ABOUT TRUMP AND HIS STAFF,
HIS TEAM OR ANY OF HIS
SUPPORTERS BEHIND CLOSED DOORS?
I SHUDDER TO THINK WHAT THEY
SAID.
YOU KNOW WHAT THIS IS REALLY ALL
ABOUT.
TRYING TO REVIVE THE PRESIDENT'S
COMMENTS ABOUT McCAIN MADE
DURING THE CAMPAIGN ABOUT HIM
BEING A P.O.W., WHICH WERE
UNFORTUNATE COMMENTS, BUT TO DO
THAT IN AN EFFORT TO SOMEHOW
HURT TRUMP NOW.
IT DIDN'T WORK THEN AND I DON'T
THINK IT WILL WORK NOW.
WHILE THE MEDIA AND THEIR
FRIENDS IN POLITICS OBSESS ABOUT
THOUGHTLESS COMMENTS AND
NONESSENTIALS, A FEW MEMBERS OF
THE MEDIA SEEM INTERESTED IN
DOING THEIR ACTUAL JOBS.
PURSUING THE STORIES THAT
ACTUALLY TOUCH AND AFFECT OUR
LIVES.
WHAT ABOUT HOLDING OUR
INSTITUTIONS ACCOUNTABLE TO MAKE
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PEOPLE THAT
PAY THE BILL.
WHY ARE THE MEDIA SO IN CURIOUS
ABOUT FBI'S INVESTIGATION OF
HILLARY CLINTON AND COMEY'S
DECISION NOT TO INDICT HER?
WHAT ABOUT THE REPORTS OF
PARTISANSHIP IN THE FBI?
POSSIBLE CORRUPTION WITHIN THE
MUELLER PRO.
WHERE IS THE REPORTING ON DEVIN
NUNES ATTEMPT TO GET THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO HAND OVER
DOCUMENTS EXPLAINING HOW THE
FBI'S RUSSIAN COLLUSION PROBE
STARTED AND WHO ACTUALLY STARTED
AT?
HE HAD TO THREATEN ROD
ROSENSTEIN WITH IMPEACHMENT
BASICALLY TO GET A RESPONSE.
AND HE STILL HASN'T SEEN ALL THE
DOCUMENTS IN QUESTION.
ISN'T THAT WORTH INVESTIGATING?
PUT TRUMP ASIDE AND WHAT YOU
THINK ABOUT HIM ASIDE.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THE
FBI STONEWALLING THOSE WITH
ACTUAL OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY.
OR HAVE PORN STARS AND RUSSIAN
COLLUSION CONSPIRACY THEORIES
SAPPED ALL THE MEDIA'S MANPOWER
AND ALL OF THEIR ENERGY AND
RESOURCES?
IF THE PRESS, THINK ABOUT THIS,
SPENT JUST A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
COVERING SOME OF THOSE STORIES,
IT MAY BE MORE AMERICANS MIGHT
LISTEN WHEN THEY REPORTED
CRITICALLY ON THE PRESIDENT.
BUT SO LONG AS THE PRESS IS JUST
A WING OF THE RESISTANCE, THEIR
AUDIENCE WILL SCATTER, IT WILL
DWINDLE AND SOON MOST OF AMERICA
WILL JUST TUNE THEM OUT.
SO GO AHEAD AND COVER CRITICISM
OF THE PRESIDENT BUT ONCE IN A
WHILE JUST TRY BALANCING OUT
WHAT SOME HONEST COVERAGE OF
SOME OF THE GROUNDBREAKING
SUCCESSES IN THE REAL
ACHIEVEMENTS.
WE ALL NEED THE PRESS TO HOLD
EVERYONE ACCOUNTABLE.
TRUMP SURELY, BUT ALSO THE OTHER